I think he's going to do well as long as
they match him up correctly and I think
they kind of started off on a bad foot
already to be honest I agree I think you
take yawn you take a guy like malcolia
is a problem for him can't find him I
think there's questions I guess what I'm
getting at his chin issues are a weight
cutting issue because he is sucking
himself down so far if that solves
itself a little bit I think that he's
going to do very well if he has any chin
issues at all the problem at 205
especially right now is there's some
straight bangers you boys guys that will
they'll step right in the fire too it's
like heavyweight power with you know
middleweight athleticism even Jamal Hill
will give him problems because Jamal is
he's so willing to fight he like he
won't shy away from that fight I guess
is what I'm getting at believes in
himself ultimately which is its own kind
of superpower Johnny Walker is probably
Taylor Made for Alex Pereira because
there's no other threat I thought that
Johnny Walker was gonna be his first
fight Alex Pierre his Reign at light
heavyweight is all going to depend on
matchups and the yawn one I was like not
to fight out give him